I had hemorrhoid surgery about a year
and a half ago and they put me I'd have
like 20 stitches up my colon so what
they did was they put me on like a
pyramid pillow like that so my ass was
in the air and they cut a sheet up and
then they put my face this is a separate
thing by the way
then they put they put my face in like a
massage hole and that's one of the times
that you don't want to be famous right
when someone's about to put stitches in
your colon and just the anesthesia
put the mask on here as I was passing
out one of the nurses looked down at my
face with my brother's a big fan of
yours adjustable Tyler Perry is actually
my son's favorite comedian my son loves
big large women who bash people over the
head and yell at him I swear - I said I
said to win once I said are you funny
like daddy goes no I'm funny like Madaya
country I have to live in the same
country as Donald Trump how crazy did it
get it's gotten pretty crazy he said
that we should stop this last week he
said we should stop letting people in
from shit-housed countries fit all
countries [ __ ] countries and let
people in from Norway but this is what
he doesn't realize countries like Haiti
and stuff like that people want to leave
those countries because they are [ __ ]
off it's like Norway's kind of nice
yeah we don't want to be a tall blonde
women is a picture of me I'd have to sit
next to the entire time where I look
thinner than I do now with one eyebrow
every single publicity photo of me is
just like one eyebrow and what people
don't know is as a child I had a stroke
and that's why I did why are you
laughing no it's not it's what happened
to a services line that's why yeah he
had like a mild stroke and he's a kid
and that's when we'll tase him and do
that in person age the guy has an actual
physical difficulty we mocked the hell
out of it people do that to his face -
like people meet him the rows slide
yeah he had a tough childhood you almost
died I think the fact that can bathe
himself in millions of dollars probably
make sense the probability by himself is
just really nice dr. drew he comes to me
and he said are we having a charity
auction and we're gonna auction off some
clothing that celebrities having there's
like a pair of Elton John shoes and my
carry gave something and everyone signs
it because can you give anything so I
gave one of my leather jackets that was
off one of my specials I signed the
inside of it and I also gave the DVD of
the special I was wearing the jacket and
that was really nice that's a nice thing
but then I got obsessed and I kept on
checking the online auction every day
and it just wasn't getting bid on
so I started bidding for it
to put the price up and then it got to a
stage where I had paid more for the
jacket than it was going for in the
celebrity auction so I bought the thing
back I gave the money I've still got the
jacket
[Applause]
that deserves a testicle yeah I'm doing
a big show here what happens is I can
sell a lot of tickets there's about ten
comics in the world that can sell this
many tickets there used to be more but
then louis c.k started masks in front of
people there is never been a dildo a
vibrator or any sex toy that has been
sold with a foreskin no one has ever
bought a dildo and when I want an extra
bit of rubber hanging out over the name
name me one time in history where extra
skin on a human being was a good thing
we're like an old person to that Turkey
next thing we're - oh I've been looking
forward to this
oh yeah women love extra skin Oh like
when some 500-pound person loose 300
pounds look at that big elephant ear a
scheme and the doctor doesn't go what
keep that if I was you
it's so appealing on a human extra hangy
skin this is a real article this is not
a joke this is a real article that
showed up just before your last
scheduled appearance this was a real
thing in multiple today Austrian comic
actor Jim Jefferies killed in Malta
after a car crash I explained how first
of all the most offensive thing about
that is when I do die please find a
better photo yeah look at that
I've got my original teeth in that one
that's a redness that's made a baggage
carrousel taken by TMZ at LAX they're
always talking about Kim Kardashian
getting robbed I've done every TV shows
on Jimmy Kimmel and Stephen Colbert oh
so this is the first time having a great
time okay great so this is the first now
what happens at American TV is before
you do a TV show they ring you up and
they they ask what you're going to say
of course they say what story do you
want to tell what do you think you're
going to talk about whilst being on the
show and then you tell them and they go
these stories are exact what we do with
Israelis but you don't open a cab here
no one gives a [ __ ] what I'm saying of
this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
tell me is that your bus cause you found
outside I always was weird about the
Donald Trump and the grab him by the I
said why not he just grabbed him by the
thing and it's like everyone was so
offense I wasn't offended by that
statement I'm amused by it like the
grant like if he said I grabbed him by
the breast you can see that right you
can you still think it's wrong you
visually see what he might have done or
grab him by the head still weird but you
know what he did but to grab him by the
it's an inward thing right like if I
said to you I met a girl when I grabbed
it by the belly button how confused you
can feel you go did your poker and I'll
be like no did I say a poker I grabbed
oh yeah if he said I ponder by the Goa
palming makes
but to grab a that's that's that's gotta
be one meaty low-hanging fruit you get
it I don't think you got to ask this to
Sean spy yeah yeah right
like somebody's just giving birth and
you're okay I feel like I don't know my
crowd this evening no no they said they
said to me in any of you who do you
dislike most in entertainment this is a
Playboy just a print interview and I
could have said Piers Morgan or Johnny
Cash and you know Piers Morgan already
hates me Johnny Cash is dead he's not
gonna do anything and I thought that
they would they would have been good
answers but for some reason I attacked
Josh GAD now IRA I really I really don't
have anything particularly against Josh
GAD I don't when he's in a movie I'm not
excited or whatever I think he gets far
too much press because he was good in
the book of all my problem with Josh GAD
is this is that somehow he always
figures out how to sing in a movie he
could be in any mood it's gotta be in
his contract where he goes and I get to
sing her song the movie pixels with Adam
Sandler somehow he he gets the scene he
could be in the movie Sophie's Choice
and Josh GAD would figure out a way to
sing a [ __ ] song right so let me get
this straight as I find this fascinating
the actress who plays a prostitute you
guys have you guys hook up and there's a
baby so what happens later on when your
your child says I have to look him in
the eye and say when I Met Your Mother I
employed her as a prostitute
I'm not gonna lie to him I'm gonna be
honest yes we're very happy and the
child we have a little baby is called
Hank and it's it's all working out great
although I'm like I'm never gonna give
him a television I give him TV cuz I
don't want a little bastard writing on
the walls
thank you thank you like these French
people come on like how good the TV must
have been in French yeah I wouldn't have
won either
yeah you're watching the cross on
Channel I want to because it's
everybody how do you know 41 I'm horny
yeah like soul mates we never thrown a
kiss I don't think so
come on I don't think you'll be my first
love that's really weird
[Applause]
because that's what piece Morgan tried
to do when everyone was banging because
JK Rowling's tweeted about how happy she
was that I told Pierce we're gonna [ __ ]
off and then and he went he sent a
message to her like listen to this
horrible pedophilic joke that [ __ ]
Jim Jefferies said this is your hero JK
I like that and if people like oh that's
disgusting but the majority internet
went oh that's Jim because I was doing a
lot of grabbing by the [ __ ] jokes after
that happened yeah and then people like
oh it was just locker room talk you've
said way worse things and it's true I
have said way worse things then grab him
by the [ __ ] and that's why I agree that
I shouldn't be President of the United
States of America